AND IN THE EAST, HEAVY SHELLING.
THIS IS AHEAD OF A PLANNED
GROUND OFFENSIVE THAT COULD MOVE
FORWARD WITHIN DAYS.
TODAY A RUSSIAN CRUISE MISSILE
HIT A RESIDENTIAL AREA KILLING
TWO PEOPLE AND INJURING 18
OTHERS.
OTHER CIVILIAN BUILDINGS IN
EASTERN UKRAINE ARE SUSTAINING
EXTENSIVE DAMAGE.
CNN'S CAMERAS WERE ROLLING WHEN
THE VILLAGE MARKET WAS ATTACKED.
A SENIOR OFFICIAL IS URGING THE
70,000 REMAINING RESIDENTS TO
EVACUATE NOW BEFORE RUSSIAN
FORCES MOVE IN.
UKRAINE KNOWS ALL TOO WELL WHAT
HAPPENED LAST TIME PUTIN'S
FORCES OCCUPIED UKRAINIAN TOWNS.
MORE THAN 900 BODIES OF
CIVILIANS HAVE BEEN DISCOVERED
SINCEWITHDREW FROM AREAS
AROUND THE CAPITAL, MANY SHOWING
SIGNS OF TORTURE, RAPE AND
BRUTAL EXECUTION.
CNN'S ED LAVANDERA IS IN THE
PORT CITY OF ODESA.
ED, YOU RECENTLY WENT TO A CITY
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY IS UNDER
ATTACK IN RETALIATION FOR THE
SINKING OF THAT FLAGSHIP, ONE OF
RUSSIA'S KEY ASSETS NOW AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE BLACK SEA.
WHAT DID YOU SEE IN THAT CITY?
>> Reporter: WELL, THE CITY OF
MYKOLAIV UNDER CONSTANT ATTACK.
THE MAYOR SAYS RUSSIAN AIR
STRIKES HIT A KINDERGARTEN
BUILDING.
WE'VE SEEN IMAGES OF A
PLAYGROUND ALSO DESTROYED BY
EXPLOSIONS.
THIS COMES AS THIS IS A CITY
BRACING FOR AN OFFENSIVE FROM
RUSSIAN FORCES.
THE CLUSTER OF EXPLOSIONS JOLTED
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD IN MYKOLAIV.
WITNESSES SAY SOME PEOPLE WERE
WALKING THEIR DOGS IN A PARK AT
THE TIME.
ONE OF THE MUNITIONS STRUCK FEET
AWAY FROM AN ORTHODOX CHURCH.
YOU CAN SEE THE IMPACT SPOT OF
ONE OF THE MUNITIONS THAT WENT
OFF THIS MORNING.
AS YOU LOOK AROUND HERE YOU CAN
SEE THE IMPACT AND THE DAMAGE
DONE TO THE CHURCH HERE AS WELL.
MULTIPLE PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND
MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHERS
INJURED.
PARAMEDICS TREATED VICTIMS ON
THE SCENE.
ACROSS THE STREET THIS MAN TOLD
US HE HELPED DRAG TWO INJURED
PEOPLE INTO A STORE FOR SAFETY.
>> Translator: THE NOISE, THE
NOISE OF A ROCKET FLYING AND
EXPLOSIONS.
THAT'S WHAT I SAW AND HEARD WHEN
HE WAS IN THE SHOP.
PEOPLE RAN IN THE STORE AND I
SAW PEOPLE SCARED.
I SAW PEOPLE DROPPING TO THE
GROUND FROM EXPLOSIONS.
>> Reporter: IT STARTED AROUND
MID MORNING AND APPEARED TO
STRIKE THREE DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS.
MYKOLAIV AUTHORITIES RELEASED
THIS VIDEO OF A PRIVATE HOME
BURNING AFTER A ROCKET STRIKE.
RESIDENTS IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT RUE TALATION
OF THE "MOSKVA" WARSHIP.
IN RECENT DAYS CNN HAS WITNESSED
LONG CONVOYS OF FAMILIES FLEEING
NEAR MYKOLAIV.
THIS BOMBING STRUCK A DENSELY
POPULATED AREA.
GALINA SAYS SHE WAS BRUSHING HER
HAIR WHEN THE BOMB LANDED JUST
OUTSIDE HER APARTMENT WINDOW.
THE BLAST SHATTERED THE GLASS
AND SHATTERED HER SENSE OF
PEACE.
DID YOU THINK SOMETHING WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN TO YOU?
"I DIDN'T THINK OF ANYTHING,"
SHE TELLS ME.
"I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE END OF
THE WORLD."
THE RECENT ATTACKS HAVE CRIPPLED
PARTS OF THE CITY'S
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE WATER HAS BEEN OUT FOR THREE
DAYS FORCING HUNDREDS TO GET
WATER FROM A RIVER AND NATURAL
SPRING.
THIS MAN EVACUATED HIS MOTHER
AND PLANS TO STAY IN THE CITY TO
FIGHT OFF THE RUSSIANS.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE GETTING CLOSER?
"IT WORRIES ME A LOT," HE TELLS
ME.
IF THE RUSSIANS ARE CLOSE, I
WILL FIGHT THEM.
FOR NOW RESIDENTS ARE LEFT TO
CLEAN UP THE BLOODY AFTERMATH
AND BRACE FOR THE NEXT ATTACK.
PAULA, WE SPENT SEVERAL DAYS
TRAVELING THROUGH THE AREAS
AROUND MYKOLAIV NEAR THE FRONT
LINES AND WHAT STANDS OUT WHEN
YOU TALK TO PEOPLE, PEOPLE IN
THE CITY OF MYKOLAIV AND IN THE
REGIONS AND SMALL VILLAGES NEAR
THE FRONT LINES SAY THEY ARE
VOWING TO STAY IN FLIES, TO
FIGHT THE RUSSIANS IN THIS
EXPECTED RENEWED OFFENSIVE.
PAULA?
>> ED LAVANDERA, THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORTING.
NOW I AM JOINED BY FORMER
COMMANDING GENERAL AND SEVENTH
ARMY MARK HERTLING.
GENERAL HERTLING, WE'RE ABOUT
SIX WEEKS INTO THIS WAR.
UKRAINE HAS JUST TAKEN OUT A
CAPABLE WARSHIP.
U.S. INTEL OFFICIALS SAY THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IT HAD NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ON IT AT THE TIME.
AND NOW WE SEE RUSSIA APPEARS TO
BE RETALIATING FOR THAT.
SO IS THIS A TURNING POINT IN
THIS INVASION?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT IS, PAULA.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY AND EXECUTE
THE STRATEGIC PLAN PRESIDENT
PUTIN HAS ADJUSTED SIGNIFICANTLY
TO CONTINUE THE ATTACKS IN THE
EAST TO TAKE KEY CITIES WHICH
WILL ALLOW THEM TO HAVE MANEUVER
WARFARE AGAINST THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
I BELIEVE THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY
IS READY FOR THAT KIND OF ACTION
IN THE EAST AND IN THE SOUTH.
WE SAW ED LAVANDERA IN MYKOLAIV.
THE FIRST TIME RUSSIA ATTEMPTED
TO ATTACK THAT CITY THE
TERRITORIAL FORCES AND THE
CITIZENS FOUGHT THEM OFF.
THEIR ATTEMPT WAS TO GO FURTHER
WEST TO ODESA.
WHAT CAUSES CONCERN IN THE AREA
THERE'S A RIVER.
THE RUSSIANS CAN'T GET ACROSS
AND IF THEY CAN'T GET ACROSS
THAT RIVER AND CONDUCT AN
AMPHIBIOUS OPERATION ON THE
BEACHES NEAR ODESA, IT WILL BE
DIFFICULT TO EXTEND THEIR
OPERATIONS TO THE WEST.
>> PENTAGON OFFICIALS SAY THE
TERRAIN THERE IS DIFFERENT SO
THE FIGHTING WILL BE DIFFERENT.
CAN YOU LAY OUT HOW EXACTLY IS
THE TERRAIN DIFFERENT AND HOW IS
IT GOING TO BE DISTINCT FROM THE
URBAN WARFARE AROUND KYIV AND
WHICH SIDE HAS THE ADVANTAGE
BASED ON THOSE FACTORS?
>> THE TERRAIN NORTH IS A LOT OF
SWAMP LANDS.
THE RUSSIAN FORCES COULD NOT GET
OFF THE ROADS EVEN IF THEY HAD
WANTED TO, SO THEY WERE LIMITED
AND ROAD BOUND COMING OUT OF
CHERNIHIV AND KHARKIV.
WE DEFINE MANEUVER BY FIRE AND
MOVEMENT.
IN THE EAST IT ALSO WILL BE
DIFFICULT.
IT IS DIFFERENT TERRAIN.
IT'S FLATLAND, MORE LIKE KANSAS,
AS ADMIRAL KIRBY SAID THE OTHER
DAY, AND IT WILL BE A LITTLE BIT
EASIER TO MANEUVER FORCES.
TRUTHFULLY THE RUSSIANS HAVE NOT
SHOWN THE CAPACITY TO MANEUVER.
THEIR FORCES ARE NOT WELL
TRAINED IN THAT.
THEY ARE LACKING MANPOWER FOR
THAT RENEWED OFFENSIVE IN THE
EAST.
AND I BELIEVE THE UKRAINIAN
FORCES HAVE BEEN PREPARING
THROUGH EXERCISES AND TRAINING
EVENTS TO CONDUCT SMALL SCALE
OPERATIONS, COUNTER ATTACKS,
COUNTER MANEUVERS AGAINST
RUSSIA.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTENSE, CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF
THE FIGHTING.
I STILL LEAVE THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE THE UPPER HAND EVEN IN THE
EAST.
>> THE UKRAINIANS ARE EXPECTED
TO GET THIS HEAVY WEAPONS
SHIPMENT FROM THE U.S.
THE FACT IT'S GETTING THERE
AHEAD OF RUSSIA'S OFFENSIVE,
WILL RUSSIA BE FORCED TO SORT OF
ADJUST THEIR APPROACH HERE?
>> WELL, THEY MAY TRY, PAULA.
THIS IS THE INTERESTING THING
THOSE OF US IN THE MILITARY HAVE
BEEN WATCHING.
WE DON'T BELIEVE -- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA CAN ADJUST
THE WAY THEY'VE BEEN CONDUCTING
THEIR OPERATIONS.
THEY ARE TOO HIGH BOUND.
THEIR GENERALS DO NOT HAVE THE
ADAPTABILITY.
THE FORCE ITSELF IS NOT WELL
TRAINED.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SERGEANTS
WHO WILL DIRECT THE FORCES THAT
THE SOLDIERS CANNOT MANEUVER OFF
ROADS.
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
MAPS TO KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
GOING.
SO UKRAINE FORCES HAVE BEEN
TAUGHT THIS THE LAST TEN YEARS.
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH A
TRANSFORMATION IN THEIR
MILITARY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE QUICK
REACTION FORCES FROM THE PART OF
THE UKRAINIANS COUNTERING SOME
OF THE RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS TO GET
OFF ROADS.
INTELLIGENCE WILL BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
ALL THE NEW WEAPONS SYSTEMS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL DAYS ARE GOING TO
BE CRUCIAL ESPECIALLY THE
COUNTERARTILLERY RADAR THAT CAN
TELL WHERE RUSSIAN ARTILLERY IS
COMING FROM AND THEN THE
UKRAINIANS CAN FIGHT BACK WITH
LONG-RANGE FIRES AS WELL.
THE FACT IS WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
LOT OF NEW EQUIPMENT INSERTED
INTO THE BATTLEFIELD ON THE
UKRAINIAN SIDE.
THAT'S ALWAYS CHALLENGING FOR
ANY FORCE.
WHEN I WAS IN IRAQ AND WE WERE
DELIVERED MRAP TRUCKS, NOT A
DIFFICULT PIECE OF EQUIPMENT TO
INCORPORATE INTO THE FORCE, IT
STILL TAKES TIME TO GET USED TO
AND GET THE BUGS OUT, IF YOU
WILL.
THE UKRAINIAN FORCES WILL HAVE A
LITTLE OF THAT.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE UPPER HAND
AS THEY GO AGAINST THE RUSSIANS.
>> IT'S BEEN INTERESTING WE'VE
SEEN RUSSIA WARN OF
UNPREDICTABLE CONSEQUENCES IF
THE RUSSIAN SHIPMENTS CONTINUE
TO GO TO UKRAINE.
OBVIOUSLY THE U.S. GOING TO STOP
BECAUSE OF THIS DIPLOMATIC
MESSAGE.
SO WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
MESSAGE FROM MOSCOW?
>> IT'S A COMBINATION OF A
THREAT AND A BLUFF, PAULA.
THE RUSSIANS KNOW THEY HAVE NOT
PERFORMED WELL IN ALL ASPECTS SO
ALL THEY HAVE LEFT ARE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND CYBER ATTACKS.
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS THEY
ARE THREATENING WITHOUT SAYING
IT.
WITHOUT AN ARMY TO BACK UP THOSE
THREATS, EVEN THE THREAT OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR CYBER
ATTACKS, THAT WE HAVE HAD A LONG
TIME TO UNDERSTAND THROUGH OUR
COLLECTION OF INTELLIGENCE WHAT
THEY MIGHT BE DOING NEXT, IT'S
IMPORTANT NEVER TO UNDERESTIMATE
YOUR ENEMY BUT THESE THREATS ARE
MORE BLUFFS THAN THEY ARE
THREATS.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS ANY KIND